joining us for legal analysis Kendall
Coffey former US Attorney and Randy's
Ellen a defense attorney and former
prosecutor a Kendall first to you on
this Paul Callan had this to say earlier
on CNN about the president speaking out
on mana Ford let's play this the one
thing I would worry about as a
prosecutor if there's somebody on that
jury who's a die-hard Trump fan you have
the President of the United States
yesterday making comments about this
deliberating jury even if Jeff Sessions
said it rather than Donald Trump if a
lawyer sent it said it could be held in
contempt of court is contempt really an
issue here or is that a deflection
Kendall not not at all and look there
we're all talking heads talking about
the trial breaking it down giving
predictions and things like that the
system has to assume that the jurors are
going to honor their alts but
nevertheless if your palm anna fort this
is kind of an intriguing development
because let's face it there's got to be
statistically speaking three or four
jurors in that group that probably
supported Trump got to think that
somebody is getting word about it maybe
maybe not but when jurors go home for
the weekend do they talk to family do
they talk to friends maybe they're not
supposed to but maybe a lot of times
they do and we all know that said a lot
of people who support president Trump
don't back down easily with their views
of what the president says and what the
president believes so now you've got an
indication that there's this clear
endorsement of Paul Manafort and by the
way a very harsh condemnation of this
trial so whatever Paul Manafort has been
going through this has got to be the
last couple days two of the best days
he's had in a long time all right Randy
I mean here we are and you know the
trial the the megaphone obviously of the
president we've talked about a lot of
big paces before you've handled a lot of
big cases when you look at this how much
does that play into it with the jury and
what about the judges instructions and
the jury being charged to judge the
merits not what they hear from the
outside well working backwards you would
love to think
that jurors will honor the oath of
sympathy has no place in the courtroom
your personal feelings have no place in
the courtroom don't listen don't read
anything don't watch anything but
there's a concept that we've all learned
the right way and also the hard way
which is jury nullification which is
where a juror will say I don't care what
the law is I don't care what the judge
tells me I'm going to vote with my
conscience I'm going to vote with my
heart and be damned what the law is but
what is so bizarre here I mean this is
how everything is politicized chocolate
versus peanut butter but remember the
executive branch who sits at the top of
the executive branch the president where
does the Department of Justice fall
under the executive branch you've got
the most important person in the
executive branch basically saying that
the Department of Justice under his
watch doesn't know what it is that
they're doing what none of this makes
any sense and mr. coffee I must
respectfully disagree with because if
you as a lawyer are discussing a case
that you're involved in where that could
prejudice the Trier of the fact a juror
that is a potential disciplinary
violation we've got the most important
person in the country perhaps in the
world speaking out while the jury is
deliberating well you know Kendall as
they say in the debate business when
your name's been mentioned you get to
defend your position so what do you say
to me well of course then of course the
president has a right to speak out about
issues of public interest
he didn't plant this a reporter asked
him about the pardon issue and he
responded spontaneously and if the
suggestion is being that the president
has somehow subjected to discipline I've
got a very strongly disagree with that
but I think what was going to be
fascinating for the trial going forward
is this is a very very tough case for
Paul Manafort to win it would be one of
the biggest upsets if he got acquitted
on everything since well Donald Trump
won the election against Hillary Clinton
but what would be a big victory for man
afford and for those who opposed him Oh
investigation would be a hung jury and
so the questions we got yesterday maybe
the impact of President Trump statements
there could be some things adding up to
suggest that there at least a couple
jurors that have some skepticism about
the prosecution's case and perhaps a
reasonable doubt now it's much too early
for Paul Manafort to be getting optimism
we can we can recall cases such as
Arthur Andersen the accounting giant
such as scooter libby the former chief
of staff of Vice President Cheney where
the jury deliberated for 10 days and
came back with a guilty verdict
nevertheless it isn't a pro-prosecution
stampede and given everything that Paul
Manta Ford is facing in this trial that
might be a small glimmer of hope all
right so let's bring our Senator Chris
Murphy the Connecticut center and to the
senator into this this is what he had to
say and he tweeted this so I generally
choose not to hang on every twist of the
Mueller investigation but a trump
pardons man afford after maybe having
promised a pardon to get him not to
cooperate and gets away with it
then we're in a banana republic we just
are now he may not be the president
Randy but he is a sitting senator once
again what is happening with our system
of justice we're once upon a time yeah
transparency you can go into the
courtroom and watch what's going on but
we have everybody weighing in from a
political standpoint suddenly we're a
banana republic the point remains that
we have a system of justice that at its
essence is based upon the public's us as
citizens being confident that the right
result is going to happen and with the
political or whatever the word is
politics it's the politics everything is
about politics my god what is happening
in this country
as far as mr. Manafort is concerned he
is presumed innocent until such time as
the jurors go in and begin their
deliberations their verdict should be
based upon the evidence and nothing else
how the president feels how Senator
Murphy feels how you feel how
I feel it's simply based upon the
evidence and somehow that has so gotten
away from us
all right gentlemen thank you both I
mean great legal analysis
Kendall Randi great to see you both